hi everyone sal here from khan academy
welcome uh again for joining our
homeroom live stream uh before we get
into what's going to be a really fun
conversation with some internal khan
academy team members to talk about all
the new things we have for back to
school i will make my standard
announcements first of all a reminder
that khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist through
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about making a donation at khan
academy dot org slash donate i also want
to make a special shout out to several
organizations that when they learned
that we were running at a deficit even
before covid and that deficit only grew
because our server costs have gone up
we're trying to accelerate a whole
series of programs and and content here
at khan academy uh they stepped up to
help us fill that gap uh bank for
america google.org att fasting of
artists and also thanks to the amgen
foundation even with that very
significant support we are continuing to
run at a gap at a very large gap
actually as we go into next fiscal year
so if you're in a position to do so
please think about making a donation to
khan academy
with that i'm excited to introduce two
of my colleagues dan and sophie
to talk about uh some of what we have
going on here at khan academy in in the
coming months hey dan hey sophie
hi sal
hi sal
so so dan and we have to come up with
better terms because we have khan
academy kids and then we have the rest
of khan academy which we're starting to
sometimes call big khan academy but you
don't have to be
big or physically big to use khan
academy uh but let's start with a big
khan academy i'll turn to you dan for
that so what do we have going on and i
also want to a reminder to everyone
watching
put your questions and you can view this
as an ask us anything not just of me but
also of dan and sophie for everything
going on with khan academy can be
related to what dan and soph are going
to be talking about or anything that is
on your mind so we have team members uh
who are going to help surface some of
those questions so uh sorry i
interrupted you dan what do we have
going on dan
yep thanks al um so for for everyone
just wanted to call out you know at khan
academy here as educators as parents and
as lifelong learners we empathize with
all that you're going through right now
many of us are going through the exact
same things and khan academy is here to
help
so first of all all the resources that
we created when this whole crisis
started
in the spring we've updated them all and
they're still all available so from the
daily schedules how to get started with
khan academy
to everything's located on the keep
learning at khan academy.org which is
also available in spanish right now and
i would say really excited one of the
things that we heard loud and clear from
teachers students and parents for the
back to school is the number one thing
that's being requested is how do we keep
motivated to to learn in a distance
environment and so i'm excited to
announce two things that we're doing for
back to school the first one is learn
storm so learn storm kicked off this
monday and for those of you who don't
know learn storm is our engaging fun
motivating classroom campaign where
students work independently but it's
towards a shared classroom goal and
really it has academic content it
focuses on growth mindset and it has
motivation mechanics
for this year we're really excited
because we adapted it for distance
learning so we're connecting teachers
and students to one another to one
another really trying to ensure that
learning continues to spark that joy
and we're emphasizing digital prizes
and tips to keep distance learning
successful
and all of that's available on our
learnstorm hub and that's at
learnstorm.comacademy.org
and then secondly most excitingly that
i'm really excited about is the distance
learning survival guide for parents
so we heard loud and clear loud and
clear from parents that
there's a really big challenge in
getting kids
motivated throughout for distance
learning and so the guide really has
three areas the setup which also
includes things like how to set up your
space how to set up your time for
distance learning the second piece which
uh is all around motivation so kristen
who's our chief learning officer wrote a
starting article on how to kind of set
goals and how to keep your kids
motivated and that's a section that will
build on over time and the third piece
is around self-care so we recognize as
parents you know if you're not in a good
place um the kids will will recognize
that and they won't be in a good place
as well so we want to be mindful that um
you know to help you as parents and as
as caregivers to be mindful about
yourselves and so i want to highlight
the motivation piece because there's one
piece that's really exciting which is um
how to set up your goals how to think
about motivation and for that section
we'll be adding
new pieces and new articles throughout
the entire fall so and that's available
at conduct co slash distance learning
survival guide
yeah and i'll just add to everything
that dan and the incredible team here
that's been partnering with schools and
families to put this out has been doing
but and we've talked about this at
previous live streams but just a
reminder everything dan has talked about
is on top of everything else going on at
khan academy obviously we have all uh
especially in math starting with pre-k
we'll talk about khan academy kids in a
second but going to elementary middle
high school math kids can learn at their
own time and pace teachers parents can
have dashboards to understand where kids
are we also over the summer in
preparation for back to school
especially this covid back to school
launched our get ready for grade level
courses which we've talked about before
but that's a way to make sure that kids
have a strong foundation and to really
understand are they ready for the grade
level courses or not if they are great
if they aren't they can go back up and
and work on on work on those things uh
sophie i'll turn to you
you know khan academy kids is still a
relatively new thing uh it's been out
for almost two years now uh but if you
could just
before we even talk about all of the new
things we have for back to school just
give everyone a reminder on what khan
academy kids is
yeah hi sal khan academy kids is khan
academy's program for two to
seven-year-olds so it's for our youngest
learners
and it's a mobile app so you can
download it on your mobile device your
tablet or touchscreen chromebook from
whatever app store you use
and it's really designed to get kids
ready for kindergarten and to thrive
beyond that and
it's full of activities so it covers
math reading
social emotional learning
we get kids up moving so they're not
glued to screens it there's a creative
corner it's really diverse the whole
idea being there's much more than just
pure academics when it comes to getting
kids ready to thrive at school
and so we've been around like you said
so for not so long for a couple of years
and been beloved by families and i don't
think anything could have really
prepared us for
the school closures in march and the
demand that we would see not just from
families who were using our app for a
long time at home
but also from teachers who needed a way
to keep kids learning even from a
distance they needed to somehow connect
with little kids who were stuck at home
uh and and make sure that they were
learning everything they needed to be
ready to go to school and get through
school and thrive
so we've got some exciting things uh
that i'd love to share with you we
launched teacher tools uh for teachers
to connect with their students and we're
seeing a little demo of it here we're
seeing a teacher who's setting up their
teacher account
and one of the really cool things sal is
that teachers can actually add their
students at different developmental
levels so that's going to help teachers
personalize learning for kids who are at
home even from a distance they can have
kids who are about to see it now um you
know who are in kindergarten they can
accelerate to first grade
and then teachers can search by standard
we're aligned to the head start early
learning outcomes framework and common
core standards
they can find activities that they want
to assign to an individual student a
group of students or their whole class
and we're scanning through all of that
beautiful content now that they can
assign
and then crucially they can see how
their students are going they can see by
student they can see by standard and
checking on their entire class we're
about to see that now for an ad
equations assignment that a teacher's
assigned we can pop that up and see oh
you know john hasn't attempted ringo's
struggling kim's struggling and we can
really get a good sense of where our
kids are at even while we as teachers
are at home and our kids are stuck at
home too
so i'm excited about teacher tools it's
the first time khan academy kids has
done something
for teachers it was designed by teachers
with the help of teachers and if you're
a teacher and you're interested in
checking it out download the app and set
yourself up as a teacher
if you're a parent and you're interested
in using khan academy kids at home with
your teacher your child's teacher
then i'd encourage you to check out
khankids.org
that's
khankids.org and that link there to
distance learning is where parents can
go to find everything they need to get
started and you'll see right behind it
is the link to teacher tools
where teachers can go to figure out how
to get their class set up add their kids
and get learning so over to you sal
that's what's happening at khan academy
kids this back to school
no super exciting and i want to
emphasize everything sophie mentioned
and dan mentioned this is all free
non-commercial non-profit there's no
catch here the catches is my earlier
announcement we're philanthropically
funded so if you're in a position to do
so please donate so there's a bunch of
questions that are coming in over
youtube and facebook this first one is
for you sophie this is from facebook
shannaz galani asks
after a long thought i've decided to
homeschool my first grader for the
upcoming year is khan academy's offered
program sufficient to help him through
this process and prepare him for second
grade for the next year the year after
or should i look for other uh curricula
as well to supplement his learning how
do you think about that
yeah so haitianaz so our content is
fully aligned to the common core
standards for first grade so you'll see
all the math and ela standards that your
child needs it covered in our program i
think with anything though with this
distance learning having a balanced
curriculum and having different
resources to supplement things is always
a great idea i would say khan academy
kids is an excellent starting point you
can rest assured that it's fully aligned
to those standards that your child will
need to be learning
to get up to second grade and thrive and
it would be great to be supplemented by
other great resources out there and lots
of balanced play and outdoor time and
life skills at home as well
and just to underline what you said
sophie is uh you know obviously you
wouldn't want to just stick a kid in
front of khan academy kids and then
leave the room so to speak
but khan academy kids it does cover math
reading writing and social emotional
learning aligned with the standards so
if uh if
a child is able to
work on those standards over the course
of the year and you know we're talking
about maybe a couple of sessions of 20
minutes a day or you know maybe you know
15 minutes and a couple of sessions of
15 minutes a day uh if you do that over
time we have some efficacy studies that
it does seem to
for sure help kids learn or learn a lot
and and then the parents can feel pretty
confident that they're familiar that
they know the standards and really
they've mastered the standards as they
as they go into second grade
yeah that's right so
let's see there's other questions here
so a lot of folks and i could probably
take this one from facebook heather
reading
mafioli any chance of elementary science
based on the next generation sign
standards for k-5
uh so we hear you and we would love to
do it and obviously covet has made the
need for having elementary and middle
school science that much more important
we have a lot of high school and i would
say early college science already on
khan academy
but unfortunately we don't have the
resources to work on that just yet uh
and so you know the resources to do that
properly actually would would be pretty
significant so if you know any uh
foundations out there that are
interested uh especially in and you know
i think this was a huge need even
pre-covered but you can imagine the need
has only grown
so that we can
hopefully build out our science
progression uh eventually from k through
12 which is our goal and our and our
mission as i said we already have a lot
at the high school level
so there's a question and this maybe i
could take it but i'm i'm happy if
if dan and sophie want to jump in from
youtube yumna says can you help me
resolve one of my problems my eldest son
does not take his studies seriously he
avoids studying
i think this is a central problem i
think in in most of academics
the main barrier to actually learning
the academic material is just engagement
and i think
students at different ages at different
stages in their academic development
disengage for different reasons
i fundamentally believe and we've seen
this i've seen this anecdotally at khan
academy we've even seen a little bit of
data that kids disengage when they feel
like the the content is not for them
when they feel like the content is
either not applicable to their life they
feel like it's too easy for them and
they're bored or they feel like it's too
hard for them
and so i think a lot of what we try to
do at khan academy is first of all offer
content that can be personalized to
where the student is so what i would do
is
i don't know how old your eldest son is
but have them if they say they're
entering sixth grade have them take the
course challenge on khan academy for the
getting ready for sixth grade course and
that getting ready for that way you'll
be able to you and your son will be able
to understand how ready they are for
sixth grade and if they're if they
aren't they can fill in those gaps uh
over time and then uh they can work at
their own time and pace at the sixth
grade and to motivate them uh you know i
would remind them you could hopefully
they're watching you can remind them
that this is really interesting stuff
that's going to be really valuable uh
for for their entire life uh but what
i've seen is as people get their legs
under them and they start to master the
concepts they actually really start
enjoying the learning process i'd also
recommend you know making it a point of
interaction between you and your child
maybe you're doing your work from home
now do it right next to them so they say
hey let's work together for 20 minutes
and then we're going to take a 10-minute
break together let's work together for
30 minutes then we're going to take a
10-minute break together i think that
might make it a lot more fun for for
your child or or they could do that with
some of their friends to kind of keep
them going to have some positive peer
pressure so those are my thoughts on the
sophie dan any ideas on if a parent has
a particularly a child that seems to be
a little disengaged
yeah so i would echo a lot of the things
that you already mentioned so in our
article on how to motivate uh kirsten's
uh kristen's article on that i think the
two things you call that is one people
are more likely to do something if they
think they're successful at it and then
number two they're more likely also to
do it if they value that activity so in
our motivation article um there's a
couple recommendations first is to make
sure that you talk to your child about
the goals and making sure that there's a
shared goal
number two is just making sure that um
that the child is actually working
towards this goal so to monitoring
progress and i i think most importantly
is also to make sure that um that you
talk to the child about how those goals
relate to their values so is it a
passion that they're interested in or
what do they get out of it in the long
term as well so i think those are are
the important things and then also if
they get stuck at something so this
speaks to
being successful if they get stuck with
something that you have a process uh to
help them get out of to be unblocked
yeah
so yeah for the younger kids yeah for
younger kids one thing that we've seen
that's that's really worked and you
touched on this sal is really linking
the learning with uh play and what's
going on outside of the online
experience so
we've had you know over the summer we
had a summer camp and one of the most
popular things was a scavenger hunt and
it really was teaching counting you know
there was a counting exercising a
grouping exercise but what it amounted
to was kids really getting outdoors or
even in their apartments or wherever
they were getting moving being curious
finding things getting up and about and
talking to their family about what they
were finding and that has been one way
that we have seen kids really get into
the learning
yeah and the summer camp you mentioned
it was a digital summer camp and so
you're able to engage kids even you know
given the the the not so ideal
circumstances that we are now facing so
this next question from facebook and i
think i could at least take a first tab
at this sally vorheis says are there
tests to see what math level i should
start with uh so sally i don't know if
you're a student or if you're a parent
but let's say whether you're student or
parent we're talking about you're
entering let's say seventh or eighth
let's say seventh grade
what i would recommend is we have uh in
math something called a get ready for
seventh grade course and what you can do
is go to that course and it'll actually
prompt you to take what's called a
course challenge which samples from the
entire course for the get ready for so
this is all the foundational skills for
seventh grade
if you do well on that say you get an 80
or 90 percent that means that you're
ready for seventh grade and so then you
can start working at your own time and
pace on the seventh grade course if you
aren't doing well on that initial course
challenge if you're getting a 50 to 60
on it or or even lower that means that
you have some gaps in your knowledge
that are prerequisite skills for seventh
grade and then you can use that get
ready for seventh grade course to go
focus on the units that you're having
trouble with and then get mastery in
those skills so that you can have a
strong foundation and then you can feel
confident going into seventh grade if
you're already starting seventh grade
there's two ways to do it you can front
load with the get ready for grade level
course like i just talked about or you
could do it in parallel to while you're
doing your seventh grade course at your
own time and pace so i would say
generally speaking
if you're a student or if you're the
parent of a student you know the the
system the school system has some grade
that the the child is entering or the
store that you are entering
but we know that everyone has different
gaps in their knowledge they have
different levels of preparedness and so
that's why we created these get ready
for grade level courses so that you have
an opportunity to fill in all your
prerequisite gaps that you need so that
you have a strong foundation for your
grade level and clearly if you find
if you're ready for seventh grade and
maybe even you know a lot of the seventh
grade material you could take the course
challenge there we have a bunch of
acceleration mechanics course challenges
unit tests mastery challenges so you can
move through that quickly if you know
that material and you can imagine some
seventh graders might be even ready for
eighth or or even ninth grade material
so everything we do here at khan academy
is to help you find your learning edge
but i would definitely start with
whatever grade level you're entering in
math and we have these get ready grade
level courses all the way through
pre-calculus and obviously we have grade
level all the way through calculus but
whatever grade level you're starting
take the course challenge on the get
ready for grade level course
if you do well go into the grade level
course learn that at your own time and
pace if you didn't do so well focus on
the get ready for grade level course so
you have a strong
foundation anything anything to add uh
maybe dan to that
yes i would just say that the the course
challenges are not particularly long so
it's not like that you have to invest
three hours to take the test to take
that little quiz um so i think that's a
great way to start to just orient
yourself with with the material
so the next question a question i think
this is for sophie uh from facebook
maria mong asks i have an eager four and
a half year old who's beginning to read
do you suggest any particular courses he
will not start school until he's five
and a half due to the age cut off really
eager to begin do we test him first what
do you think sophie
yeah i mean i think that when it comes
to khan academy kids an eager four and a
half year old who's beginning to read is
exactly the target market we have
thousands of books and they can be read
to your child or your child can read
aloud i would really encourage some
co-plays or getting involved in that and
having a parent or a caregiver
working with your child through that i
think it's a great place to start and it
will you know obviously take him beyond
reading it'll be the full range of those
pre-literacy skills that your child
really needs to be ready for
kindergarten and also math and social
emotional learning and and a bunch of
other things in there so
i would recommend
an eager four and a half year old start
with khan academy kids and i think um
you'll see that reading really pick up
in no time a lot of our research shows
that uh you know we we see really big
gains over periods of like 10 or 12
weeks when kids are that young and
learning that quickly with their
pre-literacy so that's an exciting time
yeah couldn't agree more and many of you
all know i have a five and a half year
old so i can uh he was actually in those
original i guess you could call them ads
or for khan academy he's a kid that
keeps screaming every time i'm trying to
talk properly but yes khan academy kids
has has been very effective with him
it's very it's very engaging sophie and
the team have done a really incredible
job i really can't take much much credit
for for their work
another it's a related question uh from
facebook grace han can you offer an
audio function for math at least for the
early years my daughter's still learning
to read going into first grade but
really enjoys math it would also it
would be so helpful to include a
function that reads the question to her
so that she can work independently uh so
i have i'll i'll take a first stab at an
and sophie might have something to add
so grace i think what you're referring
to is if you go to our i guess you could
call it big con if you go to our website
or if you use our the formal khan
academy mobile app or tablet app
what you see is we have content that
goes as early as early learning you know
kind of the early kindergarten first
grade standards
and it's offered up the practice is
offered up in a modality very similar to
the rest of khan academy where there's
questions you might have to input either
a choice or input a number in some way
shape or form and you can imagine for
kids who are five or six years old they
might not be literate enough or have
necessarily the motor skills to fully do
that and so i have two points of advice
uh one is khan academy critics kids is a
great solution uh it sounds like your
child or your daughter is entering
first grade so khan academy kids uh
already has the first grade standards in
math on it and kind of academy kids was
designed for that age group so it's very
visual it's audio it's video it's
everything these folks that these kids
need that are kind of right at that
little cusp of of early reading and
literacy
if you uh want to use kind of big khan
academy you know a lot of that material
we we we see as a use case of maybe a a
slightly older child who needs some
remediation they might use that but it
can also be used
if you find that modality that's kind of
a more traditional modality of getting a
lot of practice and then getting some
support videos when necessary
i i would recommend being able to sit
next to them uh and uh work work on them
uh work with it that way unfortunately
we the audio functionality is a great
idea we just haven't had the bandwidth
uh to do that uh yet anything to add
sophie
yeah i would say on the khan kids side
it has been really important to have
that narrator cody bear really reading
the questions out and guiding
our younger learners through
their learning and so that there are
certainly audio prompts explaining the
question and helping students along on
khan academy kids
yep super helpful
so from facebook there's a question
sanderson asked would you say khan
academy is inclusive to support students
with disabilities
so sandra it's an excellent question and
one that we've gotten many times over
the years i mean it really depends what
the needs of the child are i would say
that you know there's an ongoing and uh
process to make khan academy as
accessible as possible uh we you know
there's different thresholds of
accessibility and we're on that journey
so i don't want to claim that we are
fully accessible for everyone yet but
we're constantly striving there uh for
students
who are hearing impaired we have
subtitles closed captions on our videos
that they're actually for the most part
done by a lot of volunteers so thank you
all volunteers um we're trying to make
the site itself much more useful and
consistent and and being able to work
with
various kind of aid type apps uh and uh
you know and we've heard analytically
depending on the special need learning
needs of the child that it can be very
useful depending on on on where the the
child is uh but we're on a journey is i
guess a simple way to say that we
definitely aren't as far as one could be
uh and and we also haven't done you know
we've done many efficacy studies on
there's over 50 efficacy studies that
have been done on khan academy but these
have been more with kind of larger
population so we haven't had a chance
yet to do it with uh
special needs populations but we've
heard some anecdotal things depending on
what what those special needs are but
you know that that's our our current uh
state of affairs
so
uh
there's a question from youtube joshua
cataville how should we know what
courses to follow on khan academy based
on what we want to learn at our current
grade level is there a career we want to
follow how do we know what classes to
take on khan academy so the first part
of it you could look at your grade level
uh
let's say i'll use the same example i
used a few minutes ago let's say you're
a seventh grader
you could go to khan academy we have get
ready for grade level courses and there
you can take the course challenge and if
you do really well on that that means
you have the foundations needed to enter
into seventh grade if you're not do not
so well on it not a big deal you can go
into that course and then focus on the
units and the skills so that you can get
mastery so you have a strong foundation
for seventh grade then you could go into
the seventh grade course work on that at
your own time and pace and you'll be
able to uh progress and and if you feel
like the seventh grade course is easy
you could take the course challenge
there the unit test there and accelerate
through that and move on to eighth grade
so that would be my advice on you know
start at your grade level and the get
ready for grade level course uh if
you're ready for grade level just move
right into that at your own time base if
you need help get ready for grade level
if you're ready to move ahead you can go
obviously beyond your grade level in
terms of connecting the learning on khan
academy 2 careers really the second part
or interest of your question you know we
don't have super robust
mechanisms for that right now
i would say and you know feel free to
add what what career you're thinking
about i could give you more specific
advice but
you know i will tell you that um pretty
much any career that you go into people
are going to want to ensure that you
have strong analytical and critical
thinking skills
and it isn't just that people are trying
to give you a hard time strong
analytical and critical thinking skills
are really valuable in almost every
career and it is true that there are
certain careers where you actually might
solve a system of equations or actually
might solve a quadratic i actually did
find myself doing both of those things
every now and then when i used to work
in finance and when i used to work in
computer science
but the ability to learn these things
and think through it and deduce it and
really understand it are skills that are
portable to almost any field and that's
why so many folks i would say especially
care about learning things like
algebra i remember
one of the early supporters of khan
academy ran a large restaurant chain
very large a publicly traded company and
he used to say that he he divides his
employees based on whether they know
algebra or not he actually you know
that's his main deciding factor on
whether they have the critical thinking
skills and the independence and the
agency to be able to become a manager a
regional manager eventually become an
executive in the organization and that's
for you know a restaurant business
that's not for uh someone who's you know
a software firm or
or a engineering firm where the math or
finance where the math or the science is
that much more valuable
and that's just the math side i would
also say you know and that khan academy
right now we definitely have the whole
pathway in math from pre-k with khan
academy kids all the way through
elementary middle high school and early
college we have sciences and things like
sat prep in high school but you know
even the things where khan academy does
not offer things i encourage you to get
as strong as possible you know during
covid try to write as much as possible
write blogs share things with folks
write stories get feedback journal as
much as you can because i can't tell you
how important that writing skill is in
your life i do in pretty much any career
today you're going to do more writing
than anything else especially a lot of
the careers that i suspect you might
aspire to same thing for reading you
cannot read too much and i would say
that's pretty much true of every career
to just be able to read communicate have
the critical thinking skills going to be
very very very valuable for you
so
oh it looks like joshua is an
engineering related career well then
it's even more directly valuable you
actually will use the algebra the
geometry the trigonometry the calculus
the statistics in your engineering so
it's directly applicable and
the humanities and and the language arts
are also going to become very important
my original degree was in computer
science and electrical engineering i
worked in technology as kind of the
first wave of my career and i can't tell
you how important it has been to be able
to write communicate have strong reading
comprehension and you know now khan
academy a lot of our team are engineers
people with technical backgrounds and
you know one of the top skills is
obviously they are they need to be able
to design and write code well and
engineer well but a lot of it is
collaboration communication uh being
able to read and understand the
direction of the organization so uh you
know it all of this stuff really matters
especially if you're going to become an
engineer but pretty much any any any
career
so let's see
if other questions is facebook lee ram
asks if students are behind because of
the pandemic how are they to manage
their time to do grade level assignments
homework and assignments they are behind
in i think each student will need an
individualized learning plan
with organizational sk learning path
with organizational skills i agree with
you lee i actually think what you
described is actually
in any year even if we weren't dealing
with a pandemic we know that kids show
up the first day of school with at all
different levels
and in the ideal world we would be able
to personalize the pace the scope what
we cover to their individual needs make
sure they can fill in their gaps and
that's why so much of our resources at
khan academy are focused on not only
creating content not only creating
exercises and videos that are helpful
but creating software that students know
how to navigate it and navigate at their
own time and pace they get different
levels of mastery on the skills parents
and teachers can monitor where those uh
kids are and that's also why we created
these things these get ready for grade
level courses we've always seen really
good results when teachers
have students uh start at the basics on
khan academy fill in all their gaps and
get to grade level and the get ready for
grade level course has really
streamlined that process so we're hoping
that especially in this pandemic but
even beyond this pandemic that khan
academy really is the place that people
go to for free non-commercial
not-for-profit but really world-class
personalized practice with immediate
feedback that has other supports videos
hints solutions
information to adults to help that
student so that kids can learn at their
own time and pace fill in any gaps they
need and then keep and then and then and
then to keep going
let's see other questions here
uh from facebook jin sugar brown says
how can the khan country bring inclusive
education across africa any initiative
happening here that you can share a
great question jin uh so i
i we we have 46 translation projects of
khan academy around the world these are
for the most part volunteer driven i
know that there's several going on in
africa i believe there's one in
afrikaans there's one in swahili and
obviously we have projects in french
large french-speaking populations in
large parts of africa uh but i would
encourage you to look at the uh the khan
academy advocate program the advocates
are the volunteers who've been doing
these various translation projects so
depending what region what language in
africa you are thinking about there
might already be a project to translate
or to redo khan academy in that
geography and there are all different
levels of fidelity depending on where
they are in that journey and how well
resourced they are and if you don't see
your language and wanted to see it maybe
you could be one of the advocates or you
can find a group of folks who can start
that effort in in your geography in your
language
so
let's see
from this is a question
uh from facebook praveen pal my daughter
is three and a half years old we'll be
taking nursery class can we start with
your course material and i think sophie
might have had to drop off i can take a
first stab at this simple interest oh
sophie's there even better so sophie
pervine's daughter is three and a half
years old can we start her on khan
academy kids and how would you recommend
doing that
yeah so
so absolutely i think starting on khan
academy kids with a three and a half
year old is a great plan so the
logistics side of it you download our
app from your app store and you can
quickly set up an account and add your
child's profile there
and then what i would recommend is
there's actually um a big play button in
the center when you come into the home
screen and that is a personalized
learning path so if you set up your
three and a half year old say as an age
three profile on khan academy kids that
personalized learning path will actually
serve up a mixture of
reading of math of social emotional
learning all the things your child needs
to be kindergarten ready at their pace
and it will adapt it will get smart to
where your child is at and i think
that's probably a great way to start um
obviously lots of parents
differ on screen time for a child of
that age and we really defer to the
american association of pediatrics on
that what our research shows is that
between about 15 and 25 minutes a day
depending on the age of your child maybe
three to five times a week is where we
start to really see those learning gains
pick up um
and and enjoy i would say go for it
awesome well i just noticed the time
goes a lot i thought we were like 10
minutes into this we're already at
at 12 35 so um i i will wrap it up we're
going to continue to be here uh we have
a uh exciting conversation tomorrow with
linda darling hammond uh education
expert stanford professor involved in
government as well to talk about
distance learning so excited about that
tomorrow but i just want to remind
everyone you know all of us here at khan
academy i want to thank sophie and dan
you know we're trying to do everything
we can to support you uh you know even
pre-covet but especially as kovit is
people doing distance learning to
support you your parents your teachers
so that we can all hold hands and get
through this together it's going to be a
hard year in a lot of ways
but i think it's also an opportunity for
us to try new things uh and and to make
sure that we can all you know
collectively support each other and keep
learning uh i i will make the
announcement just for mine folks that if
any of y'all have been enjoying these
podcasts or these lecture or these live
streams and want a podcast version of it
uh there is a podcast version homeroom
uh with sal i guess the podcast actually
wasn't involved in naming but i like the
name the podcast
homeroom the podcast um which you can
get wherever you would find podcasts
whether it's you know you're on android
or apple or wherever else people people
get podcasts so take a look at that it's
not all of our episodes but many of them
kind of edited for podcast in kind of a
listening format so with that super
excited to see y'all tomorrow the
conversation with linda darling hammond
and as always if in a position to do so
please think about making a donation to
khan academy thanks everyone
you